alright more movie news yesterday we
told you Star Trek's John Cho who plays
Sulu just revealed that his character is
gay in honor of the original Sulu gay
activist George Takei at you know who's
actually not into that George Takei
there's a rule of sci-fi and when you
break it there's a reason for it why is
Sulu suddenly gained decayed played
lieutenant Sulu as a straight character
on the original Star Trek TV series from
nineteen sixty six to nineteen
sixty-nine he did not come out publicly
until 2005 the man who created Star Trek
Gene Roddenberry is a person we are
paying tribute to its is creation it's
his vision and his philosophy and he
created Sulu as a straight character now
he's a well-known activist for the LGBT
community his reaction to yesterday's
announcement about john cho sulu
surprised a lot of people they were
expecting you to be pleased if not proud
by this time pleased that you know
they're dealing with the gay idea this
shouldn't be soon that's right exactly
George is standing by his thoughts on
Sulu and his sexuality we've lived much
longer than we expected and prospered in
so many wonderful ways